Where's the buttons?
They've installed voice recognition technology in this lift.
Voice recognition technology?
In a lift?
In Scotland?
You ever tried voice recognition technology?
No.
They don't do Scottish accents.
Eleven.
Could you please repeat that?
Whose idea was this?
You need to try an American accent.
Eleven.
That sounds Irish, not American.
Where in America is that, Dublin?
Try an English accent, all right?
Eleven.
Are you from the same part of England as Dick Van Dyke?
Please speak slowly and clearly.
Eleven.
I'm sorry, could you please repeat that?
You're just saying it the same way.
I wanna keep saying it until it understands Scottish, all right?
Just take us anywhere, you cow.
Just open the doors.
This is a voice-activated elevator.
Please state which floor you would like to go to in a clear and calm manner.
You have not selected a floor.
If you would like to get out of the elevator without selecting a floor, simply say,...
..."Open the doors, please."
Why didn't you just say please?
I'm not begging that for nothing.
Open the doors, please?
Please?
Pathetic.
Please remain calm.
Would you let me up to that, get me up there!
Right, just wait for it to speak.
You have not selected a floor.
Up yours, you cow.
If you don't open these doors, I'm going to come to America,...
...I'm going to find whatever desperate actress gave you a voice...
...and I'm gonna get an electric chair for you.
Scotland!
Freedom!
Going up?